the global citizen Festival in New York  City you would imagine that these people  are overwhelmingly Libs and then there's  Nancy Pelosi up there speaking and she's  getting booed and it's funny you hear  that one guy in the back goes why is  everybody booing I don't know the clip  that's gone viral actually doesn't give  a ton of context into specifically what  Nancy Pelosi is talking about here's why  she might be being booed because  everything that the Democrats have  touched has turned to Ash the economy  foreign policy education immigration and  everything in the middle it's all  falling apart this is why the Democrats  are underwater on every single public  policy issue this is why the Democrats  are running way way behind when you look  at the polls for the midterm election so  I'm frankly I'm not really surprised  that Nancy Pelosi is getting booed in  New York City